Ever since I got bit by that spider
I've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
That was when you found out
When you botched that spell
where you wanted everyone to forget that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man,
we started getting some visitors
From every
universe
Hello, Peter
You're not Peter Parker
I'm sorry what was your name again?
Doctor Otto Octavius
Wait, no seriously what's your actual name?
There are others out there
We need to send them back
So... Scooby-Doo this crap!
You know all this is kind of your mess
I know a couple of magic words myself
starting with the word please
Please, Scooby-Doo this crap.
You're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts
What do you mean?
They all die fighting Spider-Man
It's their fate
I'm sorry kid
Yeah me too
Don't!
Look, there has to be another way
There isn't
They're a danger to our universe
You'll never take this away from me
Peter,
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
This is all my fault
I can't save everyone
What's happening?
They're starting to come through
and I can't stop them
December 17th exclusively in movie theaters
Tickets on sale november 29th, Spider-Monday